comparison is the fastest way to
stirring up the pot of anxiety feelings
of inadequacy and so I want to encourage
you number one it's your race your pace
don't compare your growth to others
that's not going to help you stay
motivated it's going to suck away your
motivation I also want you to remember
that there's difference in niches and
topics it's absolutely the wrong thing
to compare a niche business channel to a
entertainment Channel a niche business
Channel may never experience massive
growth but it may be more than
sufficient to reach the revenue goals
compared to oh a million subscribers and
millions of views and viral videos
there's just differences